aider la Russie alors il faut dire aussi
que la Russie et c'est pas hasard si
Poutine attendu peut-être cette période
pour pour son offensive contre l'Ukraine
la Russie dans une position financière
très solide grâce aux exportations de
gaz et de pétrole dans le prix a
augmenté ces derniers mois la Russie a
engagé engrangé des milliards de dollars
elle a des réserves de change très
importantes à la banque centrale il y a
plus de 600 milliards de dollars 600
milliards de dollars ça voudrait dire
que même si la Russie n'arrivait plus à
recevoir des recettes d'exportation elle
pourrait tenir 15 mois pour continuer à
acheter ces importations il est assez
les réserves de change c'est un pays qui
est très peu endetté
la dette publique de la Russie c'est
même pas 20% du PIB c'est 18% à titre de
comparaison je vous rappelle qu'en
France c'est plus de 115%. donc la
Russie n'a même pas besoin d'un
d'emprunter pardon beaucoup sur les
marchés internationaux c'est une des
sanctions des premières sanctions qui
ont été décidé par Joe Biden de couper
l'accès de la Russie au marché
internationaux pour emprunter mais la
Russie n'est pas tellement besoin
d'emprunter parce qu'elle est dans une
situation financière saine la Russie
devrait avoir un excédent budgétaire en
2022 ou en tout cas pas de déficit je
vous rappelle qu'en Europe quasiment
tous les pays sont en déficit budgétaire
donc elle n'a pas besoin d'emprunter
elle n'est pas prise à la gorge
[Musique]
on n'a pas réussi à trouver de
supermarché il y a la queue à tous les
distributeurs on peut retirer de
l'argent que jusqu'à 3000 grivenia il y
avait plein de gens avec des valises qui
partaient enfin vraiment on sentait
qu'il y avait une panique là que ça a
changé par exemple il y avait une femme
qui essaie de retirer de l'argent avec
son fils ils avaient des ordinateurs à
la main ça se voyait qu'ils avaient été
réveillé rapidement ils étaient pas très
couverts et la femme disait
la femme disait en fait
qu'ils attendaient pas du tout ce qui
attendaient pas du tout à ça elle a dit
ils vont faire regarder ils vont faire
comme en Crimée ils vont faire dans le
don de base mais ça va être pire ce
matin on s'est réveillé à 5h du matin
avec des explosions il y en avait
plusieurs ça a duré et après en fait ça
revient régulièrement on est monté sur
le toit de l'hôtel pour avoir une vue et
il y avait
il y avait envoyé au loin la fumée en
fait je sais pas trop si c'est en
direction d'aéroport mais je peux
vérifier en tout cas on continue à
rendre des bombardements de temps en
temps c'était vraiment des grosses
explosions qui sont répétées toutes les
quelques secondes en fait
[Musique]
il y a quelques années
pas de souci
[Musique]
mais en plus on a l'impression qu'elle
bouffi quoi
les filles les garçons la drogue de
libre professionnel
les années ont fait sombrer dans une
folie toujours plus
des antennes
[Musique]
alors à la fois pris beaucoup de
d'observateurs de diplomates par
surprise et si l'une des forces de
Vladimir Poutine on le compare souvent à
un joueur d'échec mais c'est Vladimir
federovski le célèbre écrivain russe
basé en France qui aime bien et qu'il
rappelait il y a un ou deux jours il
disait faut pas oublier que Vladimir
Poutine est aussi un judoka donc qui en
permanence utilise la faiblesse de
l'adversaire pour avancer pour pour
porter ses coups et donc à la fois
Vladimir Poutine est compliqué à lire
parce que techniquement à court terme il
est capable de mentir en permanence ça
veut dire pas plus tard que cette nuit
il nous dit non non mais pas question
d'envahir l'Ukraine effectivement il y a
une énorme confusion sur le terrain mais
d'après ce qu'on lit sur les dépêches
d'après ce que ce que disent différents
envoyés spéciaux il semblerait qu'il y
ait quand même des troupes qui est
franchi plusieurs points à la frontière
là encore faut être prudent la situation
est quand même extrêmement confuse donc
à la fois court terme il est capable de
semer la confusion de mentir de prendre
tout le monde par entreprise mais si on
regarde parfois si on prend du recul ces
objectifs sont très clairs et j'ai
changé hier avec un diplomate des pays
baltes donc d'anciens citoyens de
l'Union soviétique qui connaissent très
bien la Russie et qui me disait vous
occidentaux vous avez été surpris par la
violence du discours de Poutine lundi
soir ce discours émaillé de référence
historique il me faisait pour nous il
n'y a rien de neuf c'est ce qu'il dit
depuis 20 ans et effectivement pour
comprendre Poutine cette fameuse phrase
qu'il a dit il y a longtemps
pour dire que
le démantèlement de l'Union soviétique
était la pire catastrophe géopolitique
de l'histoire c'est un fil rouge qui
permet vraiment de comprendre ce qui le
mène depuis 20 ans effectivement ce qui
le pousse et ça permet de comprendre
beaucoup de choses ce qu'on a du mal
aussi nous en Occident en Europe
occidentale à comprendre c'est qu'on n'a
pas le même cynisme la même brutalité
dans notre logiciel et on oublie
certains faits par exemple
un peu un péché originel de Poutine on
oublie parfois que en 1999 quand Poutine
obscure et inconnue patron du FSB
l'héritier du KGB est nommé Premier
ministre par Boris Eltsine
dans les semaines qui suivent
surviennent plusieurs attentats durant
l'été 99 la Moscou l'un dans le Caucase
et assez vite on a su il y a toujours
des débats là-dessus mais que des agents
du FSB étaient clairement derrière ces
attentats et il y a eu un troisième
attentat avorter ou des agents du FSB
également été mêlés plusieurs livres
sont parus là-dessus et il apparaît
quand même assez clairement aujourd'hui
que le FSB a fomenté lui-même ses
attentats donc avec l'aval de Poutine
pour déclencher la deuxième guerre de
Tchétchénie hier soir le pouvoir de
Poutine et ce sont des manières de
procéder parfois qu'on oublie parce que
c'est pas dans nos manières de faire en
Occident mais ça permet de comprendre la
Russie de Poutine toi qui a été est-ce
qu'on peut s'imaginer que la Russie se
retrouve un peu rock sur elle même au
final alors en partie oui après la
Russie n'est pas isolée une des
questions qui se posent c'est que fera
par exemple la Chine
d'ailleurs une des premières réactions
diplomatiques de la Chine ce matin c'est
surtout une machine Pékin impact
condamné les opérations militaires
russes à la différence de tout
l'Occident mais dit la Russie est un
pays indépendant en gros elle fait ce
qu'elle veut quand même un signal fort
il y a des liens économiques quand même
assez fort entre la Chine et la Russie
la Chine pourrait sont des pays
frontaliers aider la Russie alors il
faut dire aussi que la Russie et c'est
pas hasard si Poutine a attendu
peut-être cette période pour pour son
offensive contre l'Ukraine la Russie
dans une position financière très solide
grâce aux exportations de gaz et de
pétrole dans le prix a augmenté ces
derniers mois la Russie a engagé
engrangé des milliards de dollars elle a
des réserves de change très importantes
à la banque centrale il y a plus de 600
milliards de dollars 600 milliards de
dollars ça voudrait dire que même si la
Russie n'arrivait plus à recevoir des
recettes d'exportation elle pourrait
tenir 15 mois pour continuer à acheter
ces importations il est assez les
réserves de change c'est un pays qui est
très peu endetté
la dette publique de la Russie c'est
même pas 20% du PIB c'est 18 % à titre
de comparaison je vous rappelle qu'en
France est plus de 115%. donc la Russie
n'a même pas besoin d'un apport
d'emprunter pardon beaucoup sur les
marchés internationaux c'est une des
sanctions des premières sanctions qui
ont été décidées par Joe Biden de couper
l'accès de la Russie au marché
internationaux pour emprunter mais la
Russie n'a pas tellement besoin
d'emprunter parce qu'elle est dans une
situation financière saine la Russie
devrait avoir un excédent budgétaire en
2022 ou en tout cas pas de déficit je
vous rappelle en Europe quasiment tous
les pays sont en déficit budgétaire donc
elle n'a pas besoin d'emprunter elle
n'est pas prise à la gorge
[Musique]
avec lequel
je vais continuer s'il vous plaît
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
la guerre contre notre pays
président de l'Ukraine monsieur Zelenski
vient de faire un appel au peuple
de cette déclaration
aujourd'hui on donne des armes à tous
ceux qui acceptent de s'engager dans les
Forces Armées et s'engager pour défendre
l'Ukraine
l'unité de toutes les forces politiques
ukrainiennes
craignent dans le système bancaire
fonctionne parfaitement
nous considérons cet acte d'agression
non seulement comme une guerre contre
l'Ukraine
c'est dans un article 51 de la Charte de
l'ONU
[Musique]
conscient de la situation puisque en
Russie enfin de la part de la Russie on
déclare qu'on veut libérer les régions
de domaine ski de borax
la frontière dans les environs de Raquet
en direction de Kiev en direction de la
capitale
[Musique]
lourde contre les villes pacifiques
ukrainiennes
parmi la population civile
si vous entendez dire que les Russes
n'étirent que sur les infrastructures
militaires sachez que ce n'est pas vrai
en particulier j'utilise des armes
guidées et notamment la ville de Pâques
qui a été bombardée avec les armements
Smash
courir que je vous propose
des amenant balistiques de portée
moyenne
[Musique]
explosent à des centaines de kilomètres
de la frontière la tchépoccia il s'agit
bien évidemment pas des
missiles à petite portée
je voudrais vous demander de ne plus
utiliser dans vos articles et dans vos
titres à l'expression de la crise
ukrainienne
précisément créé par Poutine et son
entourage
ont répondu
une force armées crâniennes moi je
préviens
nous avons des besoins politiques mais
aussi des besoins militaires techniques
sur le plan politique nous comptons sur
la solidarité
et les actions concrètes
nous avons vu que les demi-sansctions
n'ont pas tenu leurs promesses
[Musique]
soient introduites contre le système
financier russe les protein
en particulier
nous savons que ces questions sont
actuellement à l'étude
chose
des systèmes de défense indiennes
radio
à votre avis que veut la nouvelle
Poutine où va-t-il s'arrêter sur une
route
ce qui se passe dans la tête de Poutine
je ne sert à reconnaissant de nos enfers
parfaitement qu'il n'est pas possible de
croire à aucune déclaration avec une
parole venant de lui
de retour
certains experts pensaient que ce serait
le scénario georgien qui serait appliqué
à savoir une intervention limitée
l'occupation de territoire et les pour
parler l'espèce de ministres etc
des armes balistiques contre les villes
Pacifique
ukrainiennes comment ça peut être appelé
l'Ukraine
[Musique]
vous venez d'entendre l'ambassadeur
ukrainien en France qui a parlé d'une
guerre contre le monde civilisé il a dit
que l'Ukraine usé de son droit à se
défendre des tirs d'artillerie lourde
qui ont touché les villes d'Ukraine pour
l'instant une attaque sur plusieurs
fonds
de vous poser c'est cette attaque est-ce
qu'on pouvait s'y attendre quelque part
on pouvait aussi attendre lorsqu'on a
effectivement elle a été prévue par
Boris Johnson par Joe Biden moi elle m'a
beaucoup surprise je misaisonais pas il
faut le reconnaître humblement et je le
reconnais parce que
je croyais que Poutine était un être
rationnel je vois pas du tout ce qu'il a
à gagner à
pénétrer en Ukraine au-delà des régions
séparatistes rebelles depuis 2014 il a
déjà
sécurisé et donc effectivement
le conseiller du président Macron
conseiller diplomatique a dit qu'il
avait une vision paranoïaque depuis
quelques temps de la réalité il a parlé
d'ailleurs de nazi qui courait les rues
de Kiev non il y a pas de nazi qui court
les rues de Kiev c'est-à-dire le
Président
il faut quand même le rappeler
le président Poutine a dit que l'Ukraine
voulait se doter d'armes nucléaire
l'Ukraine a renoncé aux armes nucléaires
en décembre
1994 et le parrain de Poutine qui
s'appelait yelcine qui était le
président à l'époque a donné une
garantie d'intégrité territoriale à
l'Ukraine à ce moment-là ça s'appelle le
mémorandum de Budapest on est en
décembre 94 garantie qui était donnée
aussi par les Anglais et les Américains
donc on ne pouvait pas s'y attendre
tellement cette irrationnel si vous
voulez alors que veut-il faire veut-il
s'installer pour longtemps en Ukraine il
a dit qu'il voulait
juger les dirigeants Ukrainiens en fait
on voit un petit peu qu'il agit en
miroir de ce qu'on fait les Occidentaux
qui les Occidentaux qui se sont attaqués
par exemple à la Serbie pour détacher
militairement détacher le Kosovo de la
Serbie alors qu'il n'avait pas de les
Occidentaux de mandats de du Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU et que le temps n'a
pas de vocation agressive donc c'est un
peu en miroir et qu'ensuite les
Occidentaux ont été prendre mais le
ceviche pour le juger pour le mettre en
prison les Occidentaux ont fait la même
chose avec Saddam Hussein son mandat de
l'ONU en 2030 on était le prendre pour
le juger alors on a l'impression un peu
que la poutine singe les Occidentaux
et en faisant la même chose si vous
voulez c'est vrai que nous
occidentaux nous avons sans doute pas
suffisamment pris au sérieux les
avertissements de Vladimir Poutine qui
ne remonte pas à Yerres le premier qui
était soi-même et qu'on n'a pas pris
très au sérieux c'est en février
2007 à la conférence de sécurité de
Munich où il avait dit stop à le temps
parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a eu des
promesses
mais verbal du secrétaire des Américains
Baker qui était venu à Moscou qui avait
promis à Gorbat shop après que
Gorbatchev a retiré les soldats
soviétiques d'Allemagne de l'Est on
avait promis que le temps ne se
tendrait pas vers l'est de plus que les
Soviétiques et des pays de l'Est avaient
démantelé leur organisation militaire
qui s'appelle le
comecone c'est justement cette expansion
de l'OTAN qui pousse la plaie pardon le
Pacte de Varsovie cette organisation
militaire qui s'appelle le Pacte de
Varsovie c'est bien cette cette
expansion de l'OTAN et la raison pour
laquelle finalement Poutine passe à
l'action aujourd'hui enfin c'est c'est
le fruit d'une longue histoire et d'une
longue voilà d'une longue chronologie et
des choses à voulu se faire
effectivement entendre il a demandé
d'ailleurs une des promesses occidentaux
de ne pas étendre
le temps à l'Ukraine ces autos
évidemment ne pouvaient pas réagir sous
la menace donc cette promesse n'a pas
été faite alors il est vrai que les
Français les Allemands qui considèrent
que c'était une provocation de maître
l'Ukraine dans le temps c'était opposé
au sommet
de le temps d'avril 2008 à Bucarest
avait mis leur veto à l'adhésion de
l'Ukraine et de la georgique et deux
anciennes républiques soviétiques a le
temps disant que c'était de la
provocation que c'était comme agitée un
chiffon rouge devant Moscou et donc mais
c'était Georges W Bush le même qui avait
envahi l'Irak en 2003 qui voulait mettre
l'Ukraine dans le temps mais les
Français les Allemands n'ont pas été
assez clair c'est à dire ah peut-être
dans 20 ans ou 30 ans c'est envisageable
il luttait sans doute plus SAS à ce
moment-là de mettre un veto
général en disant voilà le temps c'est
suffisamment élargi il n'a pas vocation
assez largir davantage vous parlez tout
à l'heure d'un acte irrationnel de la
part de selon moi oui parce que je ne
vois pas ce qu'il a à gagner du tout si
vous voulez
il va encore braquer davantage le peuple
ukrainien contre les Russes ce peuple
Kenya n'avait rien contre les Russes
auparavant c'est c'est il faut connaître
que ce sont des frères et d'ailleurs
l'ambassadeur là il parlait en russe si
vous voulez et voilà il parle tous russe
etc ils sont les Moscou étaient dirigés
par des Russes brejnef fameux braisé qui
dit des régimes soviétique dans les
années 60-7080 il était
ukrainien khutchauffe avant lui il était
ukrainien donc si vous voulez c'est
vraiment le même les histoires liées
c'est l'histoire complètement liée
puisqu'en fait les
Ukrainiens les Cosaques saporogue comme
on disait en 1654 donc ça remonte à plus
de 3 c'est à 3,5 ont voulu se mettre
sous la protection du tsar Alexis le
deuxième des Romanov et donc ils sont
ensemble si vous voulez je fais des
russes depuis c'est 154
et beaucoup du crédits ont eu les plus
hautes fonctions au sein du kebab donc
donc mais mais il faut dire aussi que
les Russes ont accepté et ont démantelé
eux-mêmes l'Union soviétique c'est pas
ce sont pas les Occidentaux qui sont
allés arracher l'Ukraine aux Russes
c'est un arrangement qui s'est fait dans
un dans une sorte de chalet dans une
forêt dîner entre le président de la
Russie il signe le président de
l'Ukraine et le président de la
Biélorussie sous ceviche qu'ils ont
décidé de démanteler l'Union soviétique
parce que chacun voulait prendre le
pouvoir par rapport à quelqu'un qui
était au dessus d'eux qui était Mireille
qui dirigeait l'URSS mais le patron le
parrain de Poutine c'est lui qui a
démantelé l'Union soviétique c'est lui
qui a reconnu l'Ukraine c'est lui qui a
envoyé un ambassadeur en Ukraine c'est
lui qui a donné une garantie
territoriale à l'Ukraine en décembre
1994 qu'est-ce qu'on peut attendre alors
c'est très compliqué de faire de la
prospective mais qu'est-ce qu'on peut
attendre aujourd'hui de cette de cette
guerre que vient de déclencher Vladimir
Poutine en Ukraine jusqu'où il peut
aller est-ce que c'est vraiment dans son
intérêt d'essayer de de finalement de
s'installer là-bas alors on ne sait pas
on ne sait pas encore
jusqu'où il va aller alors déjà il va
sans doute si vous voulez étendre les
deux le territoire des deux républiques
séparatistes qui l'a reconnu à ce qu'on
appelle leurs oblast parce que c'était
du code des départements si vous voulez
on dit ça en russe on appelle ça des
oblast oui il va qui vont un petit peu
il va étendre ça c'est sûr qu'il va le
faire bon parce que c'est dans la
constitution de ces républiques
séparatistes qu'il a reconnu alors la
question ensuite est-ce qu'il va aller à
Mario Paul Mario Paul c'est une ville
sur la mer d'Azov et ça va ça
permettrait de faire la continuité
territoriale avec la presqu'île de
Crimée qui n'est relié que par un pont
tout à l'est de la Crimée sur le des
trois qu'on appelle le détroit de kirsch
et donc est-ce qu'il va conquérir pour
faire de la mère d'azoffre une mère
intérieure russe c'est assez possible ça
est-ce qu'il va aller jusqu'au grandes
villes occuper des grandes villes de
Russie je pense à carcov je pense à
Odessa et bien sûr la capitale Kiev
ça serait un peu fou mais c'est pas
impossible surtout qu'il a dit qu'il
voulait des nazifier le régime des
naziés le régime ça veut dire quoi c'est
dire aller chercher physiquement et
faire tomber le président zeninski et le
juger si vous voulez donc c'est ça ce
que ça veut dire donc j'imagine si vous
le prendre très au sérieux j'imagine
qu'il veut aller à Kiev d'autant plus
qu'on a des informations comme quoi des
chars russes et divisions blindées
russes ont pénétrer depuis la
Biélorussie et donc vous savez il y a
peut-être 100 km entre la frontière
biélorus et Kiev et donc ils peuvent
très bien se diriger vers très
rapidement
on voit justement ces images en ce
moment enfin en ce moment c'est des
images qui ont été tourné ce matin à
Sene kifka c'est la frontière entre la
Russie et la Biélorussie c'est ce que
craignait effectivement les Ukrainiens
d'avoir une invasion qui vient aussi de
la Biélorussie tout à fait parce que la
Biélorussie c'est un pays allié
de Poutine qui a réprimé si vous voulez
une révolution nationale
pro-européenne le président
s'est fait élire en manipulant un peu
les yeux urnes et donc ils sont très ils
sont très alliés il y a eu
en accord avec le président russe
lucachenko donc des divisions blindées
russes qui se sont installés sur le
territoire de la Biélorussie Poutine
nous avait dit que c'était pour des
manœuvres et bien c'est maintenant on
est au-delà des manœuvres on est dans
l'invasion de ce pays qui avait pourtant
reconnu
officiellement dont l'indépendance a été
officiellement reconnue par la Russie
donc c'est effectivement une nouvelle
ère qui qui s'annonce c'est une
violation flagrante du droit
international et de tous les engagements
de la Russie en ayant pris des prétextes
parce qu'il a dit Poutine a dit que les
séparatistes les rebelles de données
nous avons des reportés un peu partout
là-bas c'est totalement faux il y a eu
aucun tille n'est-ce pas des Ukrainiens
contre ces régions séparatistes ne sont
pas du tout inquiétées il y a pas de
nous avons nos Français nos propres
satellites d'observation nous n'avons
pas du tout remarqué de concentration de
troupes ukrainiennes à la frontière à la
limite à la je veux dire plutôt à la
ligne de Cécile feu devant ces
territoires séparatistes qui sont où le
tableau le drapeau russe flotte
d'ailleurs depuis 2000 l'été 2014 la
lumière Poutine parle justement de
défense en fait dans son intervention
dans son allocution à la télévision il a
parlé de se défendre finalement et c'est
quelque chose en réaction à ce qu'on lui
faisait oui alors l'obsession
de la lumière Poutine et que l'Ukraine
rentre dans l'OTAN et que ensuite les
Américains déploient des missiles face à
Moscou et il a dit
alors c'est vrai les rues sont un
argument les Américains n'avaient pas
particulièrement apprécié qu'un pays qui
était totalement indépendant qui
s'appelait Cuba
et accepter que un autre pays
indépendant qui était l'Union soviétique
en 1962 installa des mystiques qui donc
menacé la Floride puisque Cuba c'est à
450 km de la Floride et les Américains
avaient pas blocus qui est un acte de
guerre avait exigé que les Russes
retirent leur missile de Cuba ce qui
avait été fait mais il y avait eu en
fait un deal avec entre coup de chauffe
l'Ukrainien qui dirigeait Moscou et et
ne dit c'est à dire qu'en fait ne dit
plusieurs mois plus tard à retirer les
missiles de l'OTAN qui étaient déployés
non loin l'Union soviétique à l'est de
la Turquie on a une question de Requiem
fordrim qui nous demande est-ce que la
neutralité de l'Ukraine est finalement
impossible ou était-elle impossible à
avoir puisque c'était rapprochée de
l'OTAN alors c'est sûr que les
dirigeants ukrainiennes n'ont pas fait
le choix de cette neutralité ils
auraient tout à fait pu dire nous nous
proclamons neutralité nous n'adhérerons
jamais à le temps ils ne l'ont pas fait
est-ce qu'ils auraient été
attaquer quand même on peut pas le
savoir on peut pas mais avec des si on
mettrait Paris en bouteille mais c'est
sûr que ce n'est pas le choix qu'a fait
le président zzky puisque le ZK qui a
accepté des armements Américains et les
Américains en livrer
750 missiles Javelin ce sont les
missiles anti-charentes guidée très
performant les Turcs ont livré aussi des
drones d'attaque c'est drone qui ont
fait merveille dans la campagne de
l'armée
azerbaïdjanaise pour reprendre aux
Herman aux Arméniens une partie du haut
carapac ça s'est passé en septembre 2020
donc il est tout à fait certain que
Poutine a voulu réagir aussi une une
décision du gouvernement
ukrainien du premier février 2021 le
président ce qui a annoncé une
réorganisation de l'armée ukrainienne
avec des vins de la constitution de fin
brigade
il y avait jusqu'à ce qu'ils partent il
y avait jusqu'à encore il y a une
semaine des conseillers militaires
américains qui formaient les Ukrainiens
justement à l'usage de ces missiles
Jablines ainsi que des soldats anglais
qui faisaient de la formation les
Français les Allemands eux pour ne pas
mettre de l'huile sur le feu ne livrait
pas d'armes du côté européen
occidental on va dire comment peuvent
réagir maintenant l'Union européenne on
ne voit en train de sanction est-ce que
Poutine essaie de les tester pour voir
un peu jusqu'où lui peut aller très loin
moi je pense je peux prédire que la
Finlande et la Suède vont demander
prochainement mais je peux me tromper
bien sûr leur adhésion a le temps que ce
sera évidemment immédiatement accepté ça
c'est une première chose
la deuxième chose je pense qu'il va y
avoir un programme de réarmement massif
des pays européens troisième conséquent
je pense qu'il va y avoir un retour de
dizaines de milliers de soldats
américains sur le sol européen il va y
avoir évidemment
des sanctions je pense que le Nord
Stream 2 c'est-à-dire le gazoduc qui
passe par la Baltique qui amène
directement
du gaz russe aux Allemands je pense
qu'il va jamais être enfin pas
prochainement être ouvert il est il peut
fonctionner c'est-à-dire les Allemands
demain peuvent ouvrir le robinet mais là
ils ne le font pas diplomatiquement
effectivement pour les Allemands aussi
c'est assez compliqué est-ce que on se
retrouve dans un nouveau paradigme
finalement cette semaine a ouvert un
nouveau paradigme pour l'Europe oui
parce que si vous voulez le rock quand
même est très dépendante du gaz russe
alors vous allez voir les Américains
vont faire de bonnes affaires parce que
les Américains veulent nous vendre leur
gaz liquéfier leur gaz de schiste si
vous voulez donc les écologistes sont
pris entre deux feux là ils vont refuser
effectivement le gaz parce qu'il était
russe mais là ils vont devoir prendre du
gaz de schiste qui va dire des
États-Unis le
Qatar n'est pas n'a pas beaucoup pour le
moment le moyen
d'envoyer suffisamment de gaz liquéfié
à la à l'Europe à l'Europe donc
on va certainement avoir une
augmentation des prix considérables de
l'énergie dans cette crise et dans ce
bras de fer qui est en fait un bras de
fer entre l'Amérique et la Russie ou
depuis 20 ans c'est vrai l'Amérique a
considérablement excité les yeux
gagnants contre les Russes c'est tout à
fait indéniable dans ce bras de fer les
premiers qui vont payer ce sont les
Européens parce que les Américains ça va
pas leur coûter coûte cher parce qu'ils
ont très peu de relations économiques
avec les Russes alors que nous nous
avons beaucoup de relations économiques
avec les Russes ça c'est le terrain de
jeu enfin le terrain une bonne
expression peut-être mais le jeu
politique on peut parler d'un terrain de
jeu va se tout ça ça va se dérouler en
Europe et c'est les Européens qui vont
subir des conséquences c'est les
Européens qui vont en payer le prix
comme c'est souvent le cas alors
n'hésitez pas à nous continuer à nous
poser des questions je vois une question
très intéressante d'ailleurs de Solis
quid du rapprochement entre la Chine et
la Russie est-ce que la Chine était un
facteur très important à prendre en
compte dans toute cette
la Russie est importante la Chine est
importante à prendre en compte parce que
comme Joe Biden a fait l'erreur de ne
pas se les intentions dans la stratégie
on cache toujours ses intentions on va
pas te donner à son adversaire à son ami
ses intentions et Joe Biden a dit
bêtement qu'il jamais il ne viendrait à
l'aide militairement à l'Ukraine donc
évidemment c'était comme un feu orange
donner à Poutine qui sonnait servi
en revanche alors donc on peut très bien
les Chinois peuvent très bien
reprendre demain Taïwan
les États-Unis considèrent
officiellement que Taïwan fait partie du
territoire chinois on ne voit pas un
byden qui veut pas se battre pour
l'Ukraine à aller se battre pour formos
c'est quand même voilà donc ça ça peut
être une conséquence en revanche les
chinois sont très prudents à cet égard
ils n'ont pas
approuvé le mouvement de Vladimir
Poutine
il reconnaissent l'Ukraine comme un pays
indépendant et donc il y a aucune
approbation chinoise de cette invasion
il faut bien le souligner il y a un
ambassadeur chinois à Kef d'ailleurs et
là dessus
cette ce changement si vous voulez par
force du droit international très mal
vécu par les Chinois qui
n'aimaient pas si vous voulez que
les États s'arrangent le droit dans
envahir d'autres et d'ailleurs les
Chinois avaient été tout à fait contre
l'invasion
de
l'Irak par les États-Unis en 2003 alors
il s'était pas beaucoup exprimé parce
qu'à l'époque il voulait profiter de
toute la technologie américaine et
c'était ses pauvres français qui sont
allés au carton contre les Américains
sur l'invasion de l'Irak était tout de
suite puni les français bien sûr
mais mais ils étaient tout à fait
opposés ils sont tout à fait opposés
au changement des frontières
sous les sur des prétextes ou des
raisons humanitaires on a une question
de de Francis Legrand qui alors un peu
un peu caca qui dit comment la Russie
peut-elle continuer la guerre avec le
PIB de l'Espagne
en d'autres termes est-ce que la comment
la réussite peut se permettre de faire
une guerre est-ce que c'est encore une
grande puissance économique la Russie
alors le PIB de l'Espagne le PIB de
l'Italie on a toujours dit ça la guerre
ça se fait pas avec des petits chèques
le PIB si vous voulez si vous allez
prendre des cocktails à 30 euros le
cocktail George V ça fait croître
considérablement le PIB mais c'est pas
ça qui fait
la force militaire d'un pays vous pouvez
dire demander
leur avis au soldats allemands qui sont
allés avec un très gros PIB qui sont
allés envahir l'Union soviétique en 1941
non la Russie a une bonne armée une
armée qui était record réorganisée par
Vladimir Poutine les Russes ont montré
qu'il savait se battre voilà quand même
que c'est un peuple extrêmement
résilient en 2014 voilà ils ont montré
que ils ont soutenu pour leur mille
jours le siège de nailingrad par l'armée
allemande c'est un peuple résilient
c'est un peuple on ne va pas aller faire
changer la stratégie de la Russie de sa
petite sanction commerciale en disant on
va vous interdire d'apporter du
camembert ça ne marche pas avec avec la
Russie elle a une bonne armée on va voir
si les Ukrainiens se battent avec les
armes que l'on livré les Américains pour
le moment nous n'avons pas trop
de d'informations vous avez vu montré
des images où on voit en fait les chars
qui rentrent en Ukraine sans que
personne ne leur tire dessus
donc on n'est pas Yann exode comme en
France en mai40 mais il n'y a pas
vraiment pour le moment beaucoup de
combat j'en ai pas vu en tout cas il
faut demander à nous envoyer spéciaux
sur place c'est pas vu sur les images
télégiées beaucoup de combat c'est qui
fait évidemment une grande différence
avec mes 40 parce qu'en mes 40 l'armée
française avait été battue mais c'était
battue elle avait d'ailleurs perdu 80
000 hommes c'était battu courageusement
elle avait été battue par la faute des
des de l'incohérence de l'état-major
mais l'armée française c'était battu en
mai juin 1940 alors il faut aussi le
rappeler que c'est une guerre de
l'information qui se joue en ce moment
entre l'Ukraine et la Russie que les
informations sont à prendre avec des
pincettes bien évidemment on vous
conseille de continuer à nous suivre sur
le Figaro pour avoir des pour avoir des
informations on ne peut croire qu'aux
gens qu'ils ont sur place voilà et nous
avons quand par exemple les Ukrainiens
disent nous avons abattu 5 avions russes
je préférais avant de confirmer de voir
les carcasses de ces appareils je suis
pas sûr que les Ukrainiens ont vraiment
les moyens de battre des chasseurs
d'attaques sous Roy je n'en suis pas sûr
si vous voulez tant que je les aurais
pas vu je le croirais pas on a pierre
qui nous demande dans les commentaires
est-ce que la France doit rappeler son
ambassadeur à Moscou
pour consultation ou augmenter des
démarches diplomatiques en tout cas si
vous voulez je suis pas sûr moi je pense
qu'il faut toujours garder les
diplomates en poste parce qu'il faut
toujours laisser la possibilité d'une
option de discussion donc je suis contre
le rappel
d'ambassadeurs j'avais même trouvé ça
puéril quand on avait rappelé notre
ambassadeur d'Australie ou des
États-Unis
il faut voilà il faut garder en revanche
il y a une déclaration du président
Macron tout à fait clair de condamnation
de cette agression russe est-ce que je
suis je trouve que ça fait avancer le
schmilblick de rappeler notre
ambassadeur à Moscou je pense que non je
pense qu'il faut laisser notre
ambassadeur à Moscou très bien merci
beaucoup renaudira on va écouter Valérie
Pécresse maintenant qui est en train de
s'exprimer justement qui qui réagit
merci une nouvelle fois ordonne Gérard
pour tous vos éclairages et tous ces
explications c'était vraiment très
intéressant et restez avec nous sur le
Figaro on écoute Valérie Pécresse tout
de suite qui s'exprime en ce moment même
lucidité s'impose il faut que cette
lucidité soit partagée par tous en
Europe mais aussi en France
je marque mon entière solidarité avec le
peuple ukrainien comme j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire hier à
l'ambassadeur du crâne à Paris je
demande que tout soit fait pour protéger
les populations civiles et faire face à
la crise humanitaire qui se profile
je pense à nos compatriotes et je sais
tous les efforts qui sont faits
aujourd'hui pour les protéger
cette invasion appelle une réaction
immédiate
je souhaite que l'Union européenne en
coordination avec les États-Unis et le
Royaume-Uni ainsi que les autres membres
de la communauté internationale
s'accordent dans les plus brefs délais
sur les sanctions les plus fermes
ciblant personnellement les responsables
de cette guerre
je demande que l'Union européenne met en
place immédiatement un plan d'aide
répondant aux attentes de l'Ukraine
qu'il s'agisse d'aide humanitaire ou de
ces demandes spécifiques en équipements
de défense
il nous faudra attirer les leçons de
cette crise
elle place l'Union européenne au pied du
mur
elle nous oblige à relever plusieurs
défis et nous devrons prendre dans les
semaines qui viennent des initiatives
fortes
le premier défi c'est celui de la paix
sous le préalable de la règle médias des
hostilités le moment viendra comme je
l'ai proposé le 26 janvier dernier de
définir et d'organiser dans la durée une
nouvelle architecture pour la sécurité
du continent
le deuxième défi c'est celui de la
sécurité des pays membres de l'Union
européenne
nous Européens toujours solidaire dans
le temps nous devons nous doter d'une
capacité autonome de défense pour
assurer notre propre sécurité
le troisième défi face au chantage
gazier russe et celui de notre
indépendance énergétique au sein de
l'Union européenne
le dernier défi et celui de notre
souveraineté alimentaire et agricole
sur ces quatre défis la France qui
préside aujourd'hui le Conseil de
l'Union européenne doit être à
l'offensive et travailler de manière
collective
je demande la convocation sans délai de
l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat pour
débattre de la situation en application
de la Constitution
dans un monde qui n'a jamais été aussi
menaçant je m'engage si les Français me
font confiance
à doté nos forces armées des moyens
indispensables qui leur seront
nécessaires pour assurer la sécurité et
la protection de nos compatriotes ainsi
que de nos intérêts fondamentaux en
Europe et dans le monde nous devons
renforcer notre effort de défense
mesdames et messieurs
le moment grave dans lequel nous nous
trouvons
doit être désormais
un moment de responsabilité et d'action
pour nous tous
merci à tous
bien sûr on pouvait s'y attendre en la
même annoncé
dans pas mal d'articles du Figaro parce
que Poutine suit un plan de marche assez
clair établi depuis longtemps
hier soir en quittant le journal on a
prévenu nos amis
qui faisaient la permanence du soir pour
le site que ça risquait de démarrer dans
la nuit pourquoi parce que Poutine
venait de dire on ne peut pas continuer
à ignorer un génocide en cours en
Ukraine
soit dit en passant il y avait nos
envoyés spéciaux y compris dans le don
de basse
occupé par les prorus n'avait pas reçu
vu un obus tombé depuis trois jours au
moins mais bon il y avait un génocide en
cours à en croire Poutine et la
déclaration suivante c'était
il nous appelle à l'aide et c'est
toujours l'élément déclencheur dans les
interventions de la Russie
hors de ses frontières on notera aussi
que la Russie doit venir Poutine est un
pays qui n'attaque que ses amis ou ses
voisins enfin ceux qui leur ce qui lui
ressemble on se rappelle la Géorgie en
dehors et
et dans le discours que Poutine a
prononcé à 4 heures du matin toutes ces
justifications se sont retrouvées ils
parlent d'une menace constante que
poserait l'Ukraine à la Russie rappelant
encore une fois les faits c'est la
Russie qui occupe une partie de
l'Ukraine et non l'inverse mais Poutine
parle d'une menace constante que
représente la Russie l'Ukraine pour la
Russie il parle de des nazifié l'Ukraine
il reparle à nouveau de génocide voilà
il y a un plan de marche il y a il y a
eu tout un juridisme qui a été mis en
place autour de cette invasion avant
l'invasion on a on a reconnu les
républiques sécessionnistes de de don on
a passé un accord de défense avec elle
elles ont appelé Moscou en théorie du
moins à l'aide donc tout ça se fait dans
le cadre d'un accord de défense et
Poutine dans son discours va jusqu'à
citer l'article 51 de la Charte de l'ONU
qui
rappelle le droit à un prescriptif d'une
nation à l'autodéfense effectivement et
est-ce que on peut déjà rappeler un peu
comment le Figaro traite ce sujet là on
a des envoyé spéciaux sur on a trois
envoyé spéciaux sur place Alain Barrieu
notre correspondant à Moscou étant très
haut d'en basse dans la République de
denies côté prorus via la Russie et il y
est depuis maintenant 3 à 4 jours
nous avons une correspondante pigiste en
Ukraine qui se trouvait à carquif cette
nuit et qui est en train de de suivre la
route avec les réfugiés qui remontent
vers le vers Kiev et nous avons un grand
reporter Patrick Saint-Paul qui est à
Kiev depuis quelques jours ce qui pas de
souci est-ce que Alain barlouet qui se
trouve dans le domaine vous a fait part
de en tout cas de de ce qui se passait
là-bas pour l'instant lui a été témoin
de départ d'artillerie des ce qu'on
appelle les orgues de Staline là il les
voit partir mais pour l'instant il n'est
pas lui-même avec la population prorus
et russophone dudumba sous les
bombardements
on en a l'impression que Vladimir
Poutine essaye de trouver peut-être une
limite vers où peut-il aller
la question à un milliard de dollars il
dit dans sa déclaration de ce matin que
il n'a pas l'intention d'occuper
l'Ukraine moi je crois que c'est le cas
l'Ukraine c'est beaucoup trop lourd
militairement ça supposerait bien plus
que les 150 000 à 190.000 soldats qu'il
a déployé par contre ce que veut
fondamentalement Poutine c'est affaiblir
l'Ukraine déstabiliser l'Ukraine rendre
l'Ukraine en faire un repoussoir y
compris d'ailleurs pour lui et pour
l'OTAN
d'abord et à par la même occasion
j'ajouterai en faire une espèce de
contre-exemple pour les courants qui en
Russie pourrait voir une démocratie se
développer se rattacher à l'ouest en
Ukraine donc je pense que militairement
il va avancer c'est sûr puisqu'il a
reconnu les républiques sécessionnistes
dans un périmètre bien plus grand que
celui qu'elles occupe aujourd'hui qui
est le périmètre administratif des
Oblates des provinces
de deniesk et de louansk donc déjà c'est
c'est un tronçon plus important
d'Ukraine après se pose la question de
savoir s'il va
élargir contrôler en gros un tiers un
gros tiers oriental et russophone de
l'Ukraine qui pourrait aller de Cardiff
jusqu'à Mario Paul voir jusqu'à au
dessin il est question ce matin aussi
d'explosion à Odessa même si on ne peut
pas affirmer qu'il y a débarquement
amphibie pour l'instant à Odessa c'est
une très grande ville c'est c'est
compliqué mais là ça ferait quand même
et pour le reste il y a des mouvements
vers Kiev bien sûr
qui à mon avis auront pour principal
objectif de détruire des infrastructures
probablement d'affaiblir aussi le
système politique peut-être de bombarder
le Parlement la présidence d'essayer de
se débarrasser des hélaski que Poutine
ne me déteste des nazifiés une nouvelle
fois
prenant ce vocabulaire mais en gros si
dans son opération militaire il envoie
le régime actuel considéré comme
pro-occidental
aux égouts avec
avec les débris de la guerre il en sera
pas fâché du tout et il pourra aussi se
dire que peut-être le prochain le
prochain responsable ou dirigeant de
l'Ukraine sera un peu plus prudent
vis-à-vis de la Russie mais je pense que
le but militaire c'est de rendre
l'Ukraine d'en faire un repoussoir qui
ne soit plus possible de l'intégrer à
l'UE ni à l'OTAN quel que soit une sorte
d'abcès de un exemple finalement
je vous fais un exemple avec l'Ukraine
pour pour décourager à la fois la
population russe et les populations
autour qui pourraient un exemple mais
aussi un
enfin ça peut servir d'exemple à
d'autres mais l'Ukraine est quand même
la Géorgie a servi d'exemples à
l'Ukraine si vous voulez ce qui s'est
passé en 2008 et la Géorgie ne s'est
jamais vraiment totalement relevé de
cette occupation de l'océité du Sud et
de la crédit
je pense que le but de l'opération de
ukrainienne enfin russe en Ukraine en
2014 était similaire et que Poutine
s'est dit je vais déstabiliser ça
suffira à déstabiliser Ukraine il s'est
révélé depuis que ça n'avait pas
vraiment empêché cette espèce de dérive
vers l'ouest de de volonté de l'Ukraine
de se rattacher à l'ouest de d'essayer
de d'améliorer la démocratie qui est
encore beaucoup de progrès à faire
donc il fallait passer à l'étape
suivante et l'étape suivante
Poutine préfère avoir un état failli
ukrainien à sa porte que d'avoir une
Ukraine prospère démocratisée qui sert
de contre-exemple à ce que lui pratique
en Russie et qui en plus le menace tel
que lui perçoit l'attitude de l'OTAN
même si
objectivement il est quand même assez
peu probable d'abord l'OTAN n'a jamais
cherché à attaquer la Russie enfin le
temps a été conçu comme une organisation
défensive face à l'URSS
et il y a jamais eu de plan de l'OTAN
pour envahir la Russie enfin il faut il
faut rester calme et encore moins des
plans Ukrainiens pour envahir la Russie
oui il y a une asymétrie totale entre
ces deux pays en plus oui bien sûr
l'armée ukrainienne c'est 200 000 hommes
l'armée russe c'est 900000 hommes
Poutine on souligne toujours que le PIB
de la Russie c'est le PIB de l'Espagne à
peu près entre l'Espagne et l'Italie
c'est 120 famille 140 millions
d'habitants mais
Poutine a entamé il y a très longtemps
une
espèce de grande opération de
reconstruction de la d'une grande Russie
d'une Russie forte parce que grande
Russie ça va aussi une connotation
historique il veut pas rétablir l'empire
soviétique il ne veut pas non plus
rétablir la l'Empire russe mais il veut
rétablir une Russie forte et grande et
c'est passé par une rénovation de
l'armée russe très spectaculaire qui
maintenant une des armées les plus
dangereuses les plus puissantes du monde
oui et puis qui qui se déplace sur le
sur le terrain on l'avion pour l'avion
en Syrie par exemple c'est intéressant
de citer la Syrie parce que dans les
justifications de la guerre de
l'offensive russe en Ukraine Poutine
cyclarussie la Syrie étrangement il dit
de même que nous avons dû aller en Syrie
pour nous protéger des terroristes c'est
exactement c'est exactement la même
chose en Ukraine dit-il bon il n'y aura
que les convaincus qui accepteront ce
raisonnement mais il y en a des
convaincus très bien après validée c'est
Éric Zemmour qui est en train de
s'exprimer en ce moment on va l'écouter
quelques instants je vais demander à la
Régie de mettre les images d'Eric
Zemmour qui est en train de parler en ce
moment
cette ligne rouge car une solution
pacifique pouvait être obtenue oui je
propose depuis le 14 février que la
France fidèle à sa tradition de grande
puissance d'équilibre négocie en urgence
avec les États européens et la Russie un
traité consacrant la fin de l'expansion
de l'OTAN ce traité aurait plusieurs
corollaires la résolution des conflits
territoriaux en Europe orientale le
respect de la liberté et de la
souveraineté de tous les États concernés
en particulier l'Ukraine et le retrait
des troupes russes à la frontière de
l'Ukraine
il n'est pas trop tard un tel traité
devra être négocié lors d'une conférence
de la paix réunie à Paris
il nous faut une paix durable mais
l'urgence désormais est de faire taire
les armes j'appelle solennellement le
président Macron à se rendre à Moscou
puis à keV pour proposer la médiation de
la France afin d'obtenir un
cessez-le-feu immédiat comme l'avait
fait Nicolas Sarkozy en 2008 lors de la
crise géorgienne
c'est ce que je ferais si j'étais dès
aujourd'hui à la tête de l'État
aujourd'hui seule une France jouant
pleinement son rôle de puissance
d'équilibre est en mesure d'obtenir un
tel résultat la France est une puissance
nucléaire membre du Conseil de sécurité
de l'ONU au même titre que la Russie et
les États-Unis elle a donc toute
légitimité pour s'interposer et créer
les conditions d'un dialogue équilibré
l'Europe de l'Atlantique à l'Oural ne
doit pas être un champ de bataille je
l'ai dit au Mont Saint-Michel la France
a un devoir de puissance justement pour
préserver la paix cette situation
tragique
confirme qu'un renforcement significatif
de notre défense nationale est
indispensable c'est pourquoi j'ai
proposé de porter le budget de nos
armées à 70 milliards d'ici 2030 la
France doit retrouver les attributs de
sa puissance elle doit pouvoir parler
fort et d'une voix indépendante la
France ne doit se soumettre ni aux
États-Unis ni à la Russie ni à aucun
autre pays elle doit reprendre le
contrôle de son destin pour pouvoir
contribuer au retour de la paix
vive la paix vive la république et
surtout vive la France je vous remercie
oui voilà c'était la déclaration d'Eric
Zemmour candidat à la présidentielle qui
a parlé qui a dit en fait il faudrait
qu'Emmanuel Macron se rende à Moscou se
rend à Kiev comme l'avait fait Nicolas
Sarkozy
Emmanuel Macron pendant cette crise
diplomatique il a essayé de de se rendre
sur place oui et on peut lui reprocher
quand on est dans le débat politique on
pourrait lui reprocher de cette laisser
instrumentaliser par Poutine parce que
on peut s'interroger aujourd'hui compte
tenu du fait que les plans assez
transparents de de Poutine d'ailleurs il
faut il faut bien le reconnaître pour
une fois les services de renseignement
américain avait raison il nous
préparait au pire oui nous annoncer des
choses très alarmistes depuis des
semaines et des mois
manifestement il parlait d'une d'une
invasion d'envergure etc
les faits ont l'air de leur donner
raison
Poutine encore une fois a suivi une
séquence tout à fait planifiée
dans laquelle ce n'est pas un hasard si
la consacré huit heures de dialogue avec
avec Emmanuel Macron et d'autres
puisqu'il a aussi reçu au lave Scholt
etc et je pense que cette séquence
diplomatique
avait son rôle à jouer dans le timing et
la préparation de l'offensive j'ai une
dernière question Philippe parce que je
veux pas vous prendre trop de temps il y
a un journal à bouclé il y a beaucoup de
travail effectivement est-ce que on est
rentré dans un nouveau paradigme avec ce
qui vient de se passer aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'on se rend compte est-ce que
il y a il va y avoir des grands
changements
à cette semaine une guerre vous savez
comment vous la commencez vous savez
jamais comment elle se finit on est on
parle d'une guerre la première grande
opération militaire il y a eu des des
choses au carabar notamment mais on est
au 21e siècle c'est la première fois
qu'une grande capitale européenne et
bombardée au 21e siècle
si vous me demandez
si c'est un événement majeur je vous
réponds oui si vous me demandez comment
ça va finir je vous réponds je ne sais
pas et il ne faut pas effectivement trop
essayer de savoir ce qui va se passer on
vous le documentera nous bien évidemment
sur le Figaro nos envoyer spéciaux qui
sont sur place bien sûr demain beaucoup
de beaucoup beaucoup de reportages
dessus sur ce qui se passe en
Ukraine bien évidemment merci une
nouvelle fois Philippe merci à vous
d'avoir été nombreux à nous suivre on va
rester en direct ne vous inquiétez pas
puisque il y aura bientôt une
déclaration du chef de l'OTAN qui
devrait s'exprimer beaucoup de
déclarations aussi on attend une prise
de parole sûrement d'Emmanuel Macron qui
devrait intervenir dans la journée dans
la soirée merci une nouvelle fois
Philippe d'avoir été avec nous et à
bientôt sur figarolive
[Musique]
terroriste
libérez notre
Ukraine notre cher Ukraine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on ne souhaite
absolue c'est que des gantisses pour
nettoyer
[Musique]
alors à la fois pris beaucoup de
d'observateurs de diplomates par
surprise et si l'une des forces de
Vladimir Poutine on le compare souvent à
un joueur d'échec mais il y a Jones
bienvenue enfin bienvenue en tout cas
nous sommes toujours en direct pour
faire un point sur la situation sur
cette crise entre l'Ukraine on peut
parler de maintenant de guerre une
guerre entre l'Ukraine et la Russie on
va faire le point justement sur la
situation avec Marie-Hélène bonjour
Marie-Hélène bonjour la première
question c'est on va commencer par faire
un petit point donc est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer un peu ce qui se
passe et qu'est-ce qu'on a comme
information récemment si on peut faire
un petit rappel d'effets cette nuit à 4h
du matin heure française va dire Poutine
a lancé l'offensive en Ukraine des
explosions ont été entendues dans
plusieurs villes cette nuit donc qui Ève
la capitale mais aussi à Odessa et Maru
Paul des villes portuaires concrètement
c'est la deuxième force militaire
mondiale la Russie qui attaque la 22e en
réaction le président
ukrainien a ordonné à ses troupes
d'infliger un maximum de pertes aux
Russes à ce stade qui a affirme avoir
tué une cinquantaine d'occupants russes
40 soldats ukrainiens et une dizaine de
civils sont morts auquel s'ajoutent 18
personnes tuées lors d'une attaque
domicile à Odessa malgré la riposte
donc le président ukrainien a aussi
appelé la Russie a cessé immédiatement
l'invasion de son territoire quelle
était la réaction de la communauté
internationale alors depuis ce matin les
réactions s'enchaînent il y a quelques
minutes le président ukrainien vous le
dire zenenski a comparé l'invasion ruse
de l'Ukraine aux agissements de
l'Allemagne nazie pendant la Seconde
Guerre mondiale il appelle les Russes à
manifester à sortir dans les rues pour
protester contre ce qui est en train de
se passer vous venez aussi d'entendre
les déclarations de l'OTAN en direct de
Bruxelles les Alliés se réuniront
également en visioconférence demain il
se disent près à déployer les moyens
nécessaires pour défendre l'Ukraine on
parle donc de force militaire terrestre
maritime et aériennes on observe aussi
des réactions sur les sur les marchés
économiques effectivement il y a la
Banque centrale européenne qui dit
observer forcément de très près les
cours du blé ont explosé ceux du rouble
sont à l'évidence en baisse les Bourses
européennes sont aussi touchées à 12 la
Bourse de Francfort chutée de
5,17%. c'est le 2000 ans de 5,10% Paris
de
5,02% le Rostock 50 indice européen de
référence lui dégringolé de 5,20 % des
fluctuations du marché d'ailleurs que
Vladimir Poutine il y a quelques
instants à qualifier de réactions
émotionnelles il dit je le cite bien sûr
espérer l'espérer la plus passagère
possible et qu'est-ce que ça signifie
pour pour la France au final alors pour
les Français concrètement ce que ça va
signifier c'est peut-être des prix plus
chers à la pompe on a une explosion du
baril de pétrole on l'annonçait déjà
hier avec plus de 100 dollars et pour le
reste le ministre de l'économie
française Bruno Le Maire se veut
rassurant hier il rappelait que on
exporte moins de 7 milliards d'euros de
bien par an en Russie donc ça à peine 1%
de nos exportations et à l'inverse la
Russie représente moins de 2% des
importations françaises soit à peine 10
par an merci beaucoup Marie-Hélène pour
ce point sur la situation merci à vous
d'avoir été très nombreux à nous suivre
toute la matinée sur ce direct n'hésitez
pas à continuer à nous suivre ce direct
va bientôt s'arrêter mais vous pouvez
rester dessus pour continuer de
commenter vous pouvez retrouver toutes
les dernières informations sur la page
bien sûr le site web du Figaro ou nos
envoyer spéciaux on vous rappelle qu'on
a quelqu'un a donné des personnes à qui
est-ce qui continue de donner le plus
d'informations possibles et faites
attention effectivement c'est une guerre
avec beaucoup de communication de part
et d'autre et soyez certains de ce que
vous lisez ce que vous relayez merci en
tout cas d'avoir été très nombreux à
nous suivre et je vous dis à bientôt
pour d'autres live sur Figaro live
il y a la queue à tous les distributeurs
on peut retirer de l'argent que jusqu'à
3000 grivenia il y avait plein de gens
avec des valises qui partaient vraiment
on sentait qu'il y avait une panique là
que ça a changé par exemple il y avait
une femme qui essayait de retirer de
l'argent avec son fils ils avaient des
ordinateurs à la main ça se voyait
qu'ils avaient été réveillé rapidement
ils étaient pas très couverts et la
femme disait
la femme disait en fait
qu'ils attendaient pas du tout à ça elle
a dit ils vont faire regarder ils vont
faire comme en Crimée ou faire dans le
don de base mais ça va être pire ce
matin on s'est réveillé à 5h du matin
avec des explosions il y en avait
plusieurs ça a duré et après en fait ça
revient régulièrement on est monté sur
le toit de l'hôtel pour avoir une vue et
il y avait
il y avait envoyé au loin la fumée en
fait je sais pas trop si c'est en
direction d'aéroport mais je peux
vérifier en tout cas on continue à
entendre des bombardements de temps en
temps ça fait des vraiment des
qui sont répétées toutes les quelques
secondes en fait
[Musique]
alors à la fois pris beaucoup de
d'observateurs de diplomates par
surprise et si l'une des forces de
Vladimir Poutine on le compare souvent à
un joueur d'échec mais c'est Vladimir
federovski le célèbre écrivain russe
basé en France qui aime bien et qu'il
rappelait il y a un ou deux jours il
disait faut pas oublier que Vladimir
Poutine est aussi un judoka donc qui en
permanence utilise la faiblesse de
l'adversaire pour avancer pour pour
porter ses coups et donc à la fois
Vladimir Poutine est compliqué à lire
parce que techniquement à court terme il
est capable de mentir en permanence ça
veut dire pas plus tard que cette nuit
il nous dit non non mais pas question
d'envahir l'Ukraine alors effectivement
il y a une énorme confusion sur le
terrain mais d'après ce qu'on lit sur
les dépêches d'après ce que ce que
disent différents envoyés spéciaux il
semblerait qu'il y ait quand même des
troupes qui est franchi plusieurs points
à la frontière là encore faut être
prudent la situation est quand même
extrêmement confuse donc à la fois court
terme il est capable de semer la
confusion de mentir de prendre tout le
monde par surprise mais si on regarde
parfois si on prend du recul ces
objectifs sont très clairs et j'ai
changé hier avec un diplomate des pays
baltes donc d'anciens citoyens de
l'Union soviétique qui connaissent très
bien la Russie et qui me disait vous
occidentaux vous avez été surpris par la
violence du discours de Poutine lundi
soir ce discours émaillé de référence
historique il me faisait pour nous il
n'y a rien de neuf c'est ce qu'il dit
depuis 20 ans et effectivement pour
comprendre Poutine cette fameuse phrase
qu'il a dit il y a longtemps
pour dire que
le démantèlement de l'Union soviétique
était la pire catastrophe géopolitique
de l'histoire c'est un fil rouge qui
permet vraiment de comprendre ce qui le
mène depuis 20 ans effectivement ce qui
le pousse et ça permet de comprendre
beaucoup de choses ce qu'on a du mal
aussi nous en Occident en Europe
occidentale
à comprendre c'est qu'on n'a pas le même
cynisme la même brutalité dans notre
logiciel et on oublie certains faits par
exemple et un peu
[Musique]
au final alors en partie oui après la
Russie n'est pas isolée une des
questions qui se posent c'est que fera
par exemple la Chine
d'ailleurs une des premières réactions
diplomatiques de la Chine ce matin c'est
surtout une machine Pékin impact
condamné les opérations militaires
russes à la différence de tout
l'Occident mais la Russie est un pays
indépendant en gros elle fait ce qu'elle
veut quand même un signal fort
il y a des liens économiques quand même
assez fort entre la Chine et la Russie
la Chine pourrait
payer frontaliers aider la Russie alors
il faut dire aussi que la Russie et
c'est pas hasard si Poutine attendu
peut-être cette période pour pour son
offensive contre l'Ukraine la Russie
dans une position financière très solide
grâce aux exportations de gaz et de
pétrole dans le prix a augmenté ces
derniers mois la Russie a engagé
engrangé des milliards de dollars elle a
des réserves de change très importantes
à la banque centrale il y a plus de 600
milliards de dollars 600 milliards de
dollars ça voudrait dire que même si la
Russie n'arrivait
[Musique]
alors à la fois pris beaucoup de
d'observateurs de diplomates par
surprise et si l'une des forces de
Vladimir Poutine on le compare souvent à
un joueur d'échec mais c'est Vladimir
féderovsky le célèbre écrivain russe
basé en France qui aime bien et qu'il
rappelait il y a un ou deux jours
[Musique]
on n'a pas réussi à trouver de
supermarché il y a la queue à tous les
distributeurs on peut retirer de
l'argent que jusqu'à 3000 grivenia il y
avait plein de gens avec des valises qui
partaient enfin vraiment on sentait
qu'il y avait une panique là que ça a
changé par exemple il y avait une femme
qui essaie de retirer de l'argent avec
son fils ils avaient des ordinateurs à
la main ça se voyait qu'ils avaient été
réveillé rapidement ils avaient ils
étaient pas très couverts et la femme
disait
la femme disait en fait
qu'ils attendaient pas du tout ce qui
attendaient pas du tout à ça elle a dit
ils vont faire regarder ils vont faire
comme en Crimée ils vont faire dans le
don de base mais ça va être pire ce
matin on s'est réveillé à 5h du matin
avec des explosions il y en avait
plusieurs ça a duré et après en fait ça
revient régulièrement on est monté sur
le toit de l'hôtel pour avoir une vue et
il y avait
il y avait envoyé au loin la fumée en
fait je sais pas trop si c'est en
direction d'aéroport mais je peux
vérifier en tout cas on continue à
entendre des des bombardements de temps
en temps ça fait des vraiment des
grosses explosion qui sont répétées
toutes les quelques secondes en fait
[Musique]
alors à la fois pris beaucoup de
d'observateurs de diplomates par
surprise et c'est l'une des forces de
Vladimir Poutine on le compare souvent à
un joueur d'échec mais c'est Vladimir
federovski le célèbre écrivain russe
basé en France qui aime bien qu'il
rappelait il y a un ou deux jours il
disait faut pas oublier que Vladimir
Poutine est aussi un judoka donc qui en
permanence utilise la faiblesse de
l'adversaire pour avancer pour pour
porter ses coups et donc à la fois
Vladimir Poutine est compliquée à lire
parce que techniquement à court terme il
est capable de mentir en permanence ça
veut dire pas plus tard que cette nuit
il nous dit non non mais pas question
d'envahir l'Ukraine effectivement il y a
une énorme confusion sur le terrain mais
d'après ce qu'on lit sur les dépêches
d'après ce que ce que disent différents
envoyés spéciaux il semblerait qu'il y
ait quand même des troupes qui est
franchi plusieurs points à la frontière
là encore faut être prudent la situation
est quand même extrêmement confuse donc
à la fois court terme il est capable de
semer la confusion de mentir de prendre
tout le monde par entreprise mais si on
regarde parfois si on prend du recul ces
objectifs sont très clairs et je j'ai
changé hier avec un diplomate des pays
baltes donc d'anciens citoyens de
l'Union soviétique qui connaissent très
bien la Russie et qui me disait vous
occidentaux vous avez été surpris par la
violence du discours de Poutine lundi
soir ce discours émaillé de référence
historique il me faisait pour nous il
n'y a rien de neuf c'est ce qu'il dit
depuis 20 ans et effectivement pour
comprendre Poutine cette fameuse phrase
qu'il a dit il y a longtemps
pour dire que
le démantèlement de l'Union soviétique
était la pire catastrophe géopolitique
de l'histoire c'est un fil rouge qui
permet vraiment de comprendre ce qui le
mène depuis 20 ans effectivement ce qui
le pousse et ça permet de comprendre
beaucoup de choses ce qu'on a du mal
aussi nous en Occident en Europe
occidentale à comprendre c'est qu'on n'a
pas le même cynisme la même brutalité
dans notre logiciel et on oublie
certains faits par exemple
un peu un péché originel de Poutine on
oublie parfois que en 1999 quand Poutine
obscure et inconnue patron du FSB
l'héritier du KGB est nommé Premier
ministre par Boris Eltsine
dans les semaines qui suivent
surviennent plusieurs attentats durant
l'été 99 la Moscou l'un dans le Caucase
et assez vite on a su il y a toujours
des débats là-dessus mais que des agents
du FSB étaient clairement derrière ces
attentats et il y a eu un troisième
attentat avorter ou des agents du FSB
également été mêlés plusieurs livres
sont parus là-dessus et il apparaît
quand même assez clairement aujourd'hui
que le FSB a fomenté lui-même ses
attentats donc avec l'aval de Poutine
pour déclencher la deuxième guerre de
Tchétchénie un soir le pouvoir de
Poutine et ce sont des manières de
procéder parfois qu'on oublie parce que
c'est pas dans nos manières de faire en
Occident mais ça permet de comprendre la
Russie de Poutine toi qui a été est-ce
qu'on peut s'imaginer que
la Russie se retrouve un peu rock
[Musique]
on n'a pas réussi à trouver de
supermarché il y a la queue à tous les
distributeurs on peut retirer de
l'argent que jusqu'à 3000 grivenia il y
avait plein de gens avec des valises qui
partaient enfin vraiment on sentait
qu'il y avait une panique là que ça a
changé par exemple il y avait une femme
qui essaie de retirer de l'argent avec
son fils ils avaient des ordinateurs à
la main ça se voyait qu'ils avaient été
réveillé rapidement ils étaient pas très
couverts et la femme disait
la femme disait en fait
qu'ils attendaient pas du tout ce qui
attendaient pas du tout à ça elle a dit
ils vont faire regarder ils vont faire
comme en Crimée ils vont faire dans le
dogmas mais ça va être pire ce matin on
s'est réveillé à 5h du matin
avec des explosions il y en avait
plusieurs ça a duré et après en fait ça
revient régulièrement on est monté sur
le toit de l'hôtel pour avoir une vue et
il y avait
il y avait envoyé au loin la fumée en
fait je sais pas trop si c'est en
direction d'aéroport mais je peux
vérifier en tout cas on continue à ordre
des bombardements de temps en temps ça
il est vraiment des grosses explosions
qui sont répétées toutes les quelques
secondes en fait
[Musique]
alors à la fois pris beaucoup de
d'observateurs de diplomates par
surprise et si l'une des forces de
Vladimir Poutine on le compare souvent à
un joueur d'échec mais c'est Vladimir
federovski le célèbre écrivain russe
basé en France qui aime bien qu'il
rappelait il y a un ou deux jours il
disait faut pas oublier que Vladimir
Poutine est aussi un judoka donc qui en
permanence utilise la faiblesse de
l'adversaire pour avancer pour pour
porter ses coups et donc à la fois
Vladimir Poutine est compliquée à lire
parce que techniquement à court terme il
est capable de mentir en permanence ça
veut dire pas plus tard que cette nuit
il nous dit non non mais pas question
d'envahir l'Ukraine effectivement il y a
une énorme confusion sur le terrain mais
d'après ce qu'on lit sur les dépêches
d'après ce que ce que disent différents
envoyés spéciaux il semblerait qu'il y
ait quand même des troupes qui est
franchi plusieurs points à la frontière
là encore faut être prudent la situation
est quand même extrêmement confuse donc
à la fois court terme il est capable de
semer la confusion de mentir de prendre
tout le monde par mais si on regarde
parfois si on prend du recul ces
objectifs sont très clairs et j'ai
changé hier avec un diplomate des pays
baltes donc d'anciens citoyens de
l'Union soviétique qui connaissent très
bien la Russie et qui me disait vous
occidentaux vous avez été surpris par la
violence du discours de Poutine lundi
soir ce discours émaillé de référence
historique il me faisait pour nous il
n'y a rien de neuf c'est ce qu'il dit
depuis 20 ans et effectivement pour
comprendre Poutine cette fameuse phrase
qu'il a dit il y a longtemps
pour dire que
le démantèlement de l'Union soviétique
était la pire catastrophe géopolitique
de l'histoire c'est un fil rouge qui
permet vraiment de comprendre ce qui le
mène depuis 20 ans effectivement ce qui
le pousse et ça permet de comprendre
beaucoup de choses ce qu'on a du mal
aussi nous en Occident en Europe
occidentale à comprendre c'est qu'on n'a
pas le même cynisme la même brutalité
dans notre logiciel et on oublie
certains faits par exemple
un peu un péché originel de Poutine on
oublie parfois que en 1999 quand Poutine
obscure et inconnue patron du FSB
l'héritier du KGB est nommé Premier
ministre par Boris Eltsine
dans les semaines qui suivent
surviennent plusieurs attentats durant
l'été 99 la Moscou l'un dans le Caucase
et assez vite on a su il y a toujours
des débats là-dessus mais que des agents
du FSB étaient clairement derrière ces
attentats et il y a eu un troisième
attentat avorter ou des agents du FSB
également été mêlés plusieurs livres
sont parus là-dessus et il apparaît
quand même assez clairement aujourd'hui
que le FSB a fomenté lui-même ses
attentats donc avec l'aval de Poutine
pour déclencher la deuxième guerre de
Tchétchénie hier soir le pouvoir de
Poutine et ce sont des manières de
procéder parfois qu'on oublie parce que
c'est pas dans nos manières de faire en
Occident mais ça permet de comprendre la
réussite Poutine toi qui a été est-ce
qu'on peut s'imaginer que
la Russie se retrouve un peu rock
cliquer sur elle même au final alors en
partie oui après la Russie n'est pas
isolée une des questions qui se posent
c'est que fera par exemple la Chine
d'ailleurs une des premières réactions
diplomatiques de la Chine ce matin c'est
surtout une machine Pékin impact
condamné les opérations militaires
russes à la différence de tout
l'Occident mais dit de la Russie est un
pays indépendant en gros elle fait ce
qu'elle veut quand même un signal fort
il y a des liens économiques quand même
assez fort entre la Chine et la Russie
la Chine pourrait
payer frontaliers aider la Russie alors
il faut dire aussi que la Russie et
c'est pas hasard si Poutine attendu
peut-être cette période pour pour son
offensive contre l'Ukraine la Russie
dans une position financière très solide
grâce à aux exportations de gaz et de
pétrole dans le prix a augmenté ces
derniers mois la Russie a engagé
engrangé des milliards de dollars elle a
des réserves de change très importantes
à la banque centrale il y a plus de 600
milliards de dollars 600 milliards de
dollars ça voudrait dire que même si la
Russie n'arrivait plus à recevoir des
recettes d'exportation elle pourrait
tenir 15 mois pour continuer à acheter
ces importations il est assez les
réserves de change c'est un pays qui est
très peu endetté
la dette publique de la Russie c'est
même pas 20% du PIB c'est 18 % à titre
de comparaison je vous rappelle qu'en
France est plus de 115%. donc la Russie
n'a même pas besoin
d'apporter pardon beaucoup sur les
marchés internationaux c'est une des
sanctions des premières sanctions qui
ont été décidées par Joe Biden de couper
l'accès de la Russie au marché
internationaux pour emprunter mais la
Russie n'a pas tellement besoin
d'emprunter parce qu'elle est dans une
situation financière saine la Russie
devrait avoir un excédent budgétaire en
2022 ou en tout cas pas de déficit je
vous rappelle en Europe quasiment tous
les pays sont en déficit budgétaire donc
elle n'a pas besoin d'emprunter elle
n'est pas prise à la gorge
une guerre vous savez comment vous la
commencez vous savez jamais comment elle
se finit on est on parle d'une guerre la
première grande opération militaire il y
a eu des choses au carambar notamment
mais on est au 21e siècle c'est la
première fois qu'une grande capitale
européenne et bombardée au 21e siècle si
vous me demandez
si c'est un événement majeur je vous
réponds oui si vous me demandez comment
ça va finir je vous réponds je ne sais
pas
il nous faut une paix durable mais
l'urgence désormais et de faire taire
les armes j'appelle solennellement le
président Macron à se rendre à Moscou
puis à keV pour proposer la médiation de
la France afin d'obtenir un
cessez-le-feu immédiat comme l'avait
fait Nicolas Sarkozy en 2008 lors de la
crise géorgienne
c'est ce que je ferais si j'étais dès
aujourd'hui à la tête de l'État
aujourd'hui seul une France jouant
pleinement son rôle de puissance
d'équilibre est en mesure d'obtenir un
tel résultat la France est une puissance
nucléaire membre du Conseil de sécurité
de l'ONU au même titre que la Russie et
les États-Unis elle a donc toute
légitimité pour s'interposer et créer
les conditions d'un dialogue équilibré
l'Europe de l'Atlantique à l'Oural ne
doit pas être un champ de bataille
je souhaite que l'Union européenne en
coordination avec les États-Unis et le
Royaume-Uni ainsi que les autres membres
de la communauté internationale
s'accorde dans les plus brefs délais sur
les sanctions les plus fermes ciblant
personnellement les responsables de
cette guerre
je demande que l'Union européenne met en
place immédiatement un plan d'aide
répondant aux attentes de l'Ukraine
qu'il s'agisse d'aide humanitaire ou de
ses demandes spécifiques en équipements
de défense
alors je crois que ce matin il y a deux
choses qui sont très importantes à dire
et qui sont des évidences mais qui
doivent être exprimées notre solidarité
absolue au peuple craignant qui vit dans
cette situation terrible le viol de sa
souveraineté de l'intégrité de son
territoire mais aussi évidemment la fin
de la paix de cette paix que européen
nous avons peut-être trop longtemps cru
acquises pour toujours
cette solidarité elle doit se traduire
concrètement parce que demain nous
allons sans doute faire face à une crise
humanitaire majeure et nous devons dès
aujourd'hui nous y préparer tout doit
être mis en oeuvre pour désarmer les
armées pour faire en sorte que ça
n'aille pas plus loin c'est extrêmement
grave je suis inquiet mais je pense
comme tous les Français aujourd'hui qui
vont se réveiller en entendant ces
informations
c'est trop tard d'aller chercher les
responsabilités maintenant elle est là
la guerre aux portes de notre pays il
faut tout faire tout faire pour que ça
n'aille pas plus loin on est dans une
situation inédite mais la seule chose
qui doit nous guider c'est que l'Ukraine
doit être Neutra et on est du côté de
crête c'est aussi simple que ça il y a
pas des jeux de bascule il y a pas comme
un symptôme de mes amis tant de le faire
penser des responsabilités dans les deux
camps on choisit son quand même un
moment donné on choisit son corps et on
fait preuve un peu de panache un peu de
panache pas de dire que c'est inévitable
quand un pays choisit manifestement la
guerre pour régler des questions
internationales nous condamnons
évidemment fermement ce qui est en train
de se passer il y a une escalade il
prend la responsabilité d'une escalade
absolument grave et de ce point de vue
là la France doit avoir au niveau du
Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU qui doit
être convoqué immédiatement doit avoir
une voix une voix très forte on doit
défendre nos intérêts vitaux on doit se
préparer que doit faire la France que
doit faire l'Europe reprendre des
initiatives diplomatiques ne pas
abandonner cette voie de la diplomatie
de la discussion jamais jamais il y a
bien évidemment des mesures qui sont à
prendre au niveau européen je dis bien
au niveau européen certainement
également des sanctions de façon montrer
à la Russie qu'on ne laisse pas faire
qu'on n'est pas spectateurs mais reprend
des initiatives ça veut dire aussi
reprendre le chemin de Moscou du
dialogue avec Vladimir Poutine pour
mettre en terme ce qui est aujourd'hui
l'opération militaire
[Musique]
on n'a pas réussi à trouver de
supermarché il y a la queue à tous les
distributeurs on peut retirer de
l'argent que jusqu'à 3000 grivenia il y
avait plein de gens avec des valises qui
partaient enfin vraiment on sentait
qu'il y avait une panique là que ça a
changé par exemple il y avait une femme
qui essaie de retirer de l'argent avec
son fils ils avaient des ordinateurs à
la main ça se voyait qu'ils avaient été
réveillé rapidement ils avaient ils
étaient pas très couverts et la femme
disait
la femme disait en fait
qu'ils attendaient pas du tout de toute
façon pas du tout à ça elle a dit ils
vont faire regarder ils vont faire comme
en Crimée ils vont dans le dunbase mais
ça va être pire ce matin à 5h du mat
avec des explosions il y en avait
plusieurs ça a duré et après en fait ça
revient régulièrement on est monté sur
le toit de l'hôtel pour avoir une vue et
il y avait
il y avait envoyé au loin la fumée en
fait je sais pas trop si c'est en
direction d'aéroport mais je peux
vérifier en tout cas on continue à
rendre des des bombardements de temps en
temps ça fait des vraiment des grosses
explosion qui sont répétées toutes les
quelques secondes en fait
[Musique]
la situation
et des décisions que je serai amené à
prendre
vive la république et vive la France
[Musique]
alors à la fois pris beaucoup de
d'observateurs de diplomates par
surprise et si l'une des forces de
Vladimir Poutine on le compare souvent à
un joueur d'échec mais c'est Vladimir
féderovski le célèbre écrivain russe
basé en France qui aime bien qu'il
rappelait il y a un ou deux jours il
disait faut pas oublier que Vladimir
Poutine est aussi un judoka donc qui en
permanence utilise la faiblesse de
l'adversaire pour avancer pour pour
porter ses coups et donc à la fois
Vladimir Poutine est compliquée à lire
parce que techniquement à court terme il
est capable de mentir en permanence ça
veut dire pas plus tard que cette nuit
il nous dit non non mais pas question
d'envahir l'Ukraine effectivement il y a
une énorme confusion sur le terrain mais
d'après ce qu'on lit sur les dépêches
d'après ce que ce que disent différents
envoyés spéciaux il semblerait qu'il y
ait quand même des troupes qui est
franchi plusieurs points à la frontière
là encore faut être prudent la situation
est quand même extrêmement confuse donc
à la fois court terme il est capable de
semer la confusion de mentir de prendre
tout le monde par entreprise mais si on
regarde parfois si on prend du recul ces
objectifs sont très clairs et j'ai
changé hier avec un diplomate des pays
baltes donc d'anciens citoyens de
l'Union soviétique qui connaissent très
bien la Russie et qui me disait vous
occidentaux vous avez été surpris par la
violence du discours de Poutine lundi
soir ce discours émaillé de référence
historique il me faisait pour nous il
n'y a rien de neuf c'est ce qu'il dit
depuis 20 ans et effectivement pour
comprendre Poutine cette fameuse phrase
qu'il a dit il y a longtemps
pour dire que
le démantèlement de l'Union soviétique
était la pire catastrophe géopolitique
de l'histoire c'est un fil rouge qui
permet vraiment de comprendre ce qui le
mène depuis 20 ans effectivement ce qui
le pousse et ça permet de comprendre
beaucoup de choses ce qu'on a du mal
aussi nous en Occident en Europe
occidentale à comprendre c'est qu'on n'a
pas le même cynisme la même brutalité
dans notre logiciel et on oublie
certains faits par exemple
un peu un péché originel de Poutine on
oublie parfois que en 1999 quand Poutine
obscure et inconnue patron du FSB
l'héritier du KGB est nommé Premier
ministre par Boris Eltsine
dans les semaines qui suivent
surviennent plusieurs attentats durant
l'été 99 la Moscou l'un dans le Caucase
et assez vite on a su il y a toujours
des débats là-dessus mais que des agents
du FSB étaient clairement derrière ses
attentats et il y a eu un troisième
attentat avorter ou des agents du FSB
également été mêlés plusieurs livres
sont parus là-dessus et il apparaît
quand même assez clairement aujourd'hui
que le FSB a fomenté lui-même ses
attentats donc avec l'aval de Poutine
pour déclencher la deuxième guerre de
Tchétchénie hier soir le pouvoir de
Poutine et ce sont des manières de
procéder parfois qu'on oublie parce que
c'est pas dans nos manières de faire en
Occident mais ça permet de comprendre la
réussite Poutine toi qui a été est-ce
qu'on peut s'imaginer que
la Russie se retrouve un peu rock
cliquer sur elle même au final alors en
partie oui après la Russie n'est pas
isolée une des questions qui se posent
c'est que fera par exemple la Chine
d'ailleurs une des premières réactions
diplomatiques de la Chine ce matin c'est
surtout une machine Pékin impact
condamné les opérations militaires
russes à la différence de tout
l'Occident mais dit de la Russie est un
pays indépendant en gros elle fait ce
qu'elle veut quand même un signal fort
il y a des liens économiques quand même
assez fort entre la Chine et la Russie
la Chine pourrait
frontaliers et aider la Russie alors il
faut dire aussi que la Russie et c'est
pas hasard si Poutine attendu peut-être
cette période pour communiquer
une guerre vous savez comment vous la
commencez vous savez jamais comment elle
se finit on est on parle d'une guerre la
première grande opération militaire il y
a eu des choses au carabar notamment
mais on est au 21e siècle c'est la
première fois qu'une grande capitale
européenne et bombardée au 21e siècle si
vous me demandez
si c'est un événement majeur je vous
réponds oui si vous me demandez comment
ça va finir je vous réponds je ne sais
pas
il nous faut une paix durable mais
l'urgence désormais est de faire taire
les armes j'appelle solennellement le
président Macron à se rendre à Moscou
puis à keV pour proposer la médiation de
la France afin d'obtenir un Cécé le feu
immédiat comme l'avait fait Nicolas
Sarkozy en 2008 lors de la crise Géorgie
c'est ce que je ferais si j'étais dès
aujourd'hui à la tête de l'État
aujourd'hui seule une France jouant
pleinement son rôle de puissance
d'équilibre est en mesure d'obtenir un
tel résultat la France est une puissance
nucléaire membre du Conseil de sécurité
de l'ONU au même titre que la Russie et
les États-Unis elle a donc toutes
légitimité pour s'interposer et créer
les conditions d'un dialogue équilibré
l'Europe de l'Atlantique à l'Oural ne
doit pas être un champ de bataille
je souhaite que l'Union européenne en
coordination avec les États-Unis et le
Royaume-Uni ainsi que les autres membres
de la communauté internationale
s'accorde dans les plus brefs délais sur
les sanctions les plus fermes ciblant
personnellement les responsables de
cette guerre
je demande que l'Union européenne met en
place immédiatement un plan d'aide
répondant aux attentes de l'Ukraine
qu'il s'agisse d'aide humanitaire ou de
ses demandes spécifiques en équipements
de défense
alors je crois que ce matin il y a deux
choses qui sont très importantes à dire
et qui sont des évidences mais qui
doivent être exprimées notre solidarité
absolue au peuple crinien qui vit dans
cette situation terrible le viol de sa
souveraineté de l'intégrité de son
territoire mais aussi évidemment la fin
de la paix de cette paix que européen
nous avons peut-être trop longtemps cru
à qui pour toujours et cette solidarité
elle doit se traduire concrètement parce
que demain nous allons sans doute faire
face à une crise humanitaire majeure et
nous devons dès aujourd'hui nous y
préparer tout doit être mis en oeuvre
pour désarmer les armées pour faire en
sorte que ça n'aille pas plus loin c'est
extrêmement grave je suis inquiet mais
je pense comme tous les Français
aujourd'hui qui vont se réveiller en
entendant ces informations
c'est trop tard d'aller chercher les
responsabilités maintenant elle est là
la guerre aux portes de notre pays il
faut tout faire tout faire pour que ça
n'aille pas plus loin on est dans une
situation inédite mais la seule chose
qui doit nous guider c'est que les
crèmes doit être notre allié et on est
du côté de l'Ukraine c'est aussi simple
que ça il y a pas des jeux de bascule il
y a pas comme un symptôme de mes amis
tente de le faire penser des
responsabilités dans les deux camps on
choisit son camp à un moment donné on
choisit son corps et on fait preuve un
peu de panache un peu de panache on peut
pas dire que c'est inévitable quand un
pays choisit manifestement la guerre
pour régler des des questions
internationales nous condamnons
évidemment fermement ce qui est en train
de se passer il y a une escalade il
prend la responsabilité d'une escalade
absolument grave et de ce point de vue
là la France doit avoir au niveau du
Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU qui doit
être convoqué immédiatement doit avoir
une voix une voix très forte on doit
défendre nos intérêts vitaux on doit se
préparer que doit faire la France que
doit faire l'Europe reprendre des
initiatives diplomatiques ne pas
abandonner cette voie de la diplomatie
de la discussion jamais jamais il y a
bien évidemment des mesures qui sont à
prendre au niveau européen je dis bien
au niveau européen certainement
également des sanctions de façon à
montrer à la Russie qu'on ne laisse pas
faire qu'on n'est pas spectateur mais
reprend des initiatives ça veut dire
aussi reprendre le chemin de Moscou du
dialogue avec Vladimir Poutine pour
mettre un terme à ce qui est aujourd'hui
l'opération militaire
[Musique]